Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook. You know what to do.
Don't skip the workbook. If you haven't been doing it, go back and
do it. 40daysofholiness.com if you want to get yours.
Today is day number eight. Here's our theme for today: deeper
levels of holiness are needed and possible.
So yesterday, we said that Leviticus was going to teach us a ton about
holiness and about what that means, and
today we're going to unpack that. In fact, I want to draw a diagram for you today.
I'm just going to use my hand to erase this.
Leviticus has an incredible way of illustrating holiness and
how it develops and grows. One of the core teachings of Exodus
and Leviticus is the defining of holiness as
separation. All right? As separation. So I want to draw this for you.
First of all, circle number one. Let's say this is all
people. Okay? All people. And then circle number two,
let's say this is Jews. All right? Jewish people. Okay?
And they are God's chosen people. In Leviticus, they're his people, and
they're holy
in a way that all people are not because they're separated
to God. But then there's another circle inside that,
and that would be the family, or the tribe rather, of Levi.
So the tribe of Levi is-- And I'm going to turn this where you can see
it. The tribe of Levi, God says, "It's mine.
Levi is mine," and they're holy in a way that not all the children of Israel
are. "They are dedicated," God says, "to my service in the
temple, the tabernacle." They are
dedicated in a way that all the rest of the Jews, the people of Israel,
are not. So there's another circle inside that
one, and that holiness, we're going deeper into holiness.
All right? So the next one is the family of Aaron.
Okay? So the family of Aaron, they are dedicated to the
Lord, and they wear special garments, and they have special roles.
They have even more unique roles. They do special things that
the rest of the tribe of Levi can't do.
They are holy in a way that the others are not.
So that we keep going deeper and deeper into these levels of holiness.
And if you get on further on in, you discover that there's a
perfect
physical specimen. All right? So the perfect physical specimen is
important. He says only that kind of person, and inside that
perfect specimen is the high priest. Okay?
So again, one of the core teachings of Exodus is this
defining of holiness as separation.
And this separation to God from evil
and from the common or ordinary is foundational to
understanding the concept of holiness and what God is trying to teach us.
Remember, God is separate from everything.
And this whole same diagram shows up in a ton of other ways in
Exodus. So I did it once with the priests.
You can do the same thing with other things. How about all animals?
Okay. Animals, and then we have clean
animals, and then we have a lamb, or we have sacri-- I was going to say
sacrificial animals, then we have a lamb, and then we have a perfect
lamb,
one year old, and that is the Day of Atonement. Right?
So that's a totally different issue.
And we can do it with space. How about the whole world,
and then you have the camp of Israel that's holy, and
then the tabernacle. Right? Tabernacle.
And then inside that is the holy place, and then the most
holy place, and then the Ark of the Covenant. Right?
So you can do it with space, you can do it with
all kinds of different things. You see that?
The same thing can be done with a lot of other stuff, sacrifices, leaders,
offerings, practices, days. It's
not that all of the Jews weren't holy.
It's
just that deeper levels of holiness were needed and possible.
It's not that all of the Levites weren't holy. They were.
It's just that deeper levels of holiness were needed and
possible in connecting with God. It's not just that
all of Aaron's descendants, all of Aaron's family, are not holy.
It's just that deeper levels of holiness were needed and
possible in connecting with God. Now, for just a moment,
let's pause and bring that idea to our life.
A common misunderstanding of holiness in today's world is to
believe that it's one thing. It's like all or nothing.
You get saved, you've got holiness, and you do. Praise God.
And that's it.
Now I've got it. Nothing more is needed. Nothing more is possible.
And I would just caution you that it's not
either you got it or you don't, all or nothing, because people tend to think of
it as if there's no movement, there's no growth, that
nothing more is needed or possible.
And this has produced roadblocks to some people's spiritual growth.
You see, if you don't think that anything more is needed or anything
more is possible, then you stop looking for growth and
opportunities to draw closer to the Lord and grow in your
holiness. You level off in your enjoyment of God
and your depth of your becoming like him.
You don't stay serious about continued growth if you stop
seeking and following holiness.
I taught you a couple of days ago
to relax into God's drawing of you into holiness,
but relaxing into God's continued plan of making me holy is
not the same thing as thinking I've already
arrived, and I don't need anything more.
That's a totally different thing.
So here's what I want to say and teach you today.
If you've just been saved, deeper levels of holiness are
needed and possible.
If you've been walking with the Lord for a while, guess what?
Deeper levels of holiness are needed and
possible. The deeper we go into holiness, the deeper we
go into God's essential nature. And the deeper we go into God, the
more joy and the more satisfaction we find there.
The deeper we go into God's holiness, the more useful we are to
him. And the deeper we go into God's holiness,
the more glory he gets from our lives, the more we become
like him.
Deeper levels of holiness are needed
and possible, and that's the first lesson of Exodus and Leviticus.
Let's keep going deeper.
Never stop. That's what God's got for you next.
Deeper levels of holiness. They're needed, and they're possible.
They are possible.
Let's keep going forward. Today, meditate on that, what
it looks like, and pray the sample prayer, go through your workbook, and I'll see
you back here tomorrow. Thanks for being
here.